der speicher kennen und 13 befindet sich
seit montag mit allen teilen und platz
anstieg das ist eingesetzt die
panzergrenadiere company kpc
kaderpräsenzeinheiten bestehend aus
lauter berufssoldaten und der
stabskompanie mit dem september 2018 an
fahrzeugen befindet sich am
truppenzahlen steck 25 ist polen ein
bergepanzer im 88 und in summe 40
redaktion
die panzer gerne tiere als hätte man
cries wir sind das sind fantastische
element dafür panzergrenadierbrigade
wir sind befähigt sowohl den kampf gegen
feindliche schützenpanzer als auch gegen
feindliche infanterie zu führen
das schwergewicht dieser woche ist der
kampf im urbanen umfeld
[Musik]